[Music]
my name is Hilary Brown I work at the
Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute I'm
currently studying for a PhD based on
the intestinal microbiota of the human
gosh the human intestinal microbiota is
mostly made up of bacteria in addition
to some viruses and fungi and these
bacteria act together as a community so
that they work with each other for their
own benefit but for our benefit as well
if there is an imbalance in this
community and some species increase in
abundance or others decrease this can
have a negative effect on our health we
want to understand how this community
affects our health and also identify
ways to restore this balance again the
majority of the intestinal microbiota
are beneficial but some of them can be
harmful and this is why we study them in
a cl2 lab cl2 stands for containment
level 2 and it means we have certain
safety procedures in place to protect
ourselves if you were taking antibiotics
then you're not allowed to enter the lab
this is because antibiotics while they
will kill the bacteria that are making
you sick they can also kill a lot of the
good guys which causes an imbalance in
your gut and leads you more prone to
further infection only authorized people
are allowed to work in the lab when I
entered a lab I put on a lab coat and
gloves these protect me from any
spillages or bacterial contamination
most of the bacteria that live in your
gut are anaerobic this means they cannot
survive in the presence of oxygen
because of this we work with the
bacteria in anaerobic hoods these
cabinets are sealed they are constantly
being pumped with anaerobic gas that
contains hydrogen carbon dioxide and
this keeps all of the oxygen out and
means the bacteria can survive inside
them the first thing I need to do is to
enter the anaerobic cabinet I place the
sleeves over my arms and then by
pressing these pedals I can suck all of
the air out of the sleeves the odor
pedal then blows more anaerobic gas into
the sleeves I repeat this process three
times to ensure I've removed as much
oxygen as possible before opening the
doors and entering the anaerobic College
to study these bacteria we need to grow
them on agar plates the agar that the
bacteria grow on contains lots of
nutrients that would also be present in
the human gosh when you streak the
bacteria onto a new place you can often
see new colonies growing 24 hours later
here I have an individual bacterial
species growing on a plate one of the
jobs I regularly have to do is to
restrict these on to new plates this is
because the bacteria will use up all the
available nutrients when I am working in
the anaerobic hood I have to work
aseptically this means working as clean
as possible and trying to prevent
contamination of my experiment for
example if I'm streaking bacteria on to
a new plate I will use an inoculation
loop but I will only use this loop once
after using it I will discard it and I
will use a new loop before moving on to
the next place there are two ways in
which I study these bacteria one is by
understanding their phenotype this
involves studying their biology how they
live and grow how they respond to
different environmental conditions the
other is by studying the genotype we
extract a DNA from the bacteria and then
we do whole genome sequencing of this
DNA
when the sequencing is finished
I don't analyze the data on my computer
using various PI dramatic analysis tools
using these tools I can look at how
close your relation these bacteria are
to each other and I can also identify
new species that no one is cultured
before studying the intestinal
microbiota is very exciting because it's
moving very quickly from basic research
towards therapeutics this is unusual
really for a field of biology usually it
takes a much longer time before we start
seeing new drugs and new medicines on
the marketplace
[Applause]
[Music]
you